America is home to a housing crisis and
the minimum wage isn't cutting if you
work at a restaurant retail or any
low-paying job you're probably caught up
in a financial nightmare these days the
fair market rent for a one-bedroom
apartment in the u.s. is 806 dollars but
if you're making the federal minimum
wage of 725 an hour you're spending more
than half your income to make rent when
you should really only be spending about
a third on minimum wage you'd have to
work 86 hours a week to make that happen
that's 17 hours a day Monday through
Friday sleep is overrated anyway
that 725 an hour is $15,000 a year
leaving just 375 dollars for rent every
month to really afford a one-bedroom you
need to earn a wage of 1550 per hour
next if you can even find an $800
one-bedroom in the first place good luck
with that if you live in a big city
adding to the problem is that the
federal minimum wage hasn't gone up
since 2009 that's seven years in which
prices have risen while wages for the
country's poorest workers have stayed
the same and even it stays where the
minimum wage is more than the federal
rate low-income households still suffer
often having to choose between either
pay rent or paying for basics like
groceries and medicine and while many
cities and states across the country are
raising their minimum wage that's not
the case everywhere the state of Alabama
recently declared it illegal for cities
to raise their minimum wage higher than
the federal standard blocking the city
of Birmingham's attempt to raise it to
1010 per hour so what our poor families
supposed to do all this is pushing
people out of homes and into homeless
shelters Seattle LA Portland and even
Hawaii have all declared states of
emergency when it comes to homelessness
in San Francisco is talking about doing
the same
basically the only way to solve the
affordable housing crisis is for cities
to build more affordable housing and
increase the minimum wage until then low
income households will struggle to keep
a roof over their heads in a country
that relies on them to stock it's
shelves make its meals and clean its
office building